[Music]
let's go to marie in winston-salem witch
trials north carolina what's up marie
hi dr delany how are you good how are
you
good i have an interesting one for you i
love it bring it on let's do it
okay so my mother has something called
schizoaffective disorder oh when did she
get
diagnosed uh diagnosed
about five years ago
but she has been bipolar her whole life
yeah how long did she how long did she
navigate that before
you finally got to stay that usually
people who are diagnosed with that
there's just a wake of trauma
in all the family systems before people
finally land on what actually is going
on
so she is the fourth generation of my
family with that diagnosis
and
when i was about my entire childhood she
was a rock star i mean she was an
international uh businesswoman
um six figure income just blowing it out
of the water right when i was 16
something happened nobody can
conclusively say what
and
the wake of trauma is about 13 years
she started thinking people were
following her she started thinking
people were planting bugs on her
and from someone who was achieving that
high
everybody believed her for a while and
then so you understand she got on
disability we almost lost our home you
know you understand the finances oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah
and um now they're on a steady
disability her and my father are on a
steady disability but
she has just tanked slowly over time
i'm so sorry
is what's her so let me let me pause
real here for everybody listening
schizoaffective disorders is
think um
it's like a two-layer sandwich of
no maybe it's maybe it's a it's a
burrito and the filling is
psychosis so hallucinations people are
chasing me people are following me a a
dysregulated reality wrapped up in
either
super high mania
something very similar to bipolar or
long brutal depressive episodes what is
your mom's is she's got the psychosis
does she
just bury herself or does she get real
manic
she does actually really neat cycles
that's the one blessing we were given
she sticks to her cycles
winter and summer are down fall and
spring are up great okay so there's some
sort of predictive nature to it
a little bit of the mania the the
delusions coming uh the the bugs and the
fbi are pretty solid okay the other ones
tend to come and go you got your got
your gold standard there
let's be honest yeah exactly um can we
really trust the bugs or the fbi let's i
mean come on marie
wow and there's no lab test for this and
so this usually goes undiagnosed for
years and years and years and like you
mentioned you said it perfectly
it's a slow descent into madness
that is propped up by the people around
you
right and then you start thinking you're
crazy and your dad thinks what am i what
am i losing it and all of a sudden
everybody finds himself in the mud a
little bit right
yes everybody a little bit at the time
and right now she's basically
agoraphobic she won't leave the house
because if she does leave the house
they'll come in and put stuff down right
so that's an overview
what type of care has she
gone
she has gone after her she's a religious
medication she there's no issue she
doesn't palm she's pills down the throat
it's great for her she's got
she once a month therapy we're starting
with her
she's been institutionalized several
times when things get real bad
um
and she ever been acutely suicidal
uh suicide no she's afraid of death
but she has had episodes
where she has thought they were there
and she went and got it done because she
wasn't gonna let him take her alive
gotcha okay
so it's less internal oriented violence
but external okay
yeah
um
yeah
and this has been going on i'm 29 this
has been going on since i was 16.
um and i love my mother just as much now
as i did when i was 16. let's make that
clear
um
everyone wants me to accept that mom is
just gonna be this way
and
i have a hard time with that
um and i don't know what to do with the
tension i see because my father they've
been married 36 years he's her full he
doesn't work he's a full-time caretaker
and it hurts me when there's tension in
their marriage
like when i walk in and there because
you know people with that disorder can
get aggressive like dementia
and when they pop back and forth between
the two of them it kills me because they
it wasn't like that growing up there was
they were really really good you know
and then the last one that's the kicker
is there's been one kind of strong
bipolar each generation
that has kind of progressed over into
this
and i got the lucky gene
and congratulations
you're the winner
and i don't know how to cope with the
possibility that i'm watching my future
gotcha
i just tell you thank you so much for
being brave and vulnerable and telling
your
story because i i want to generalize
this now to people who are listening
it's easy to listen to your story marie
and say oh my gosh can you imagine
but almost all of us have someone in our
family with alzheimer's or dementia or
obesity or a temper problem
and we all wonder
when does this happen to me
right when when do i
hit somebody when do i go off the rails
when do i start drinking two too many
and then three two right so all of us
have what you're describing yours is
just very acute and very unknown and
very very scary right
because yours feels out of control i
cannot drink
it's hard when you're looking at what's
happening to your mom
and so
let's let's work from
oh man
let's work from childhood back or
childhood forward okay
okay i want you to give your
body
a lot of grace
because your body has a memory
of a brilliant savant connected fun mom
it remembers that and it is constantly
looking for that again
yeah and it's a never-ending search and
so everything that's not that
cognitively you can know it but it
doesn't feel right
you get what i'm saying it feels
disoriented your body's never connected
when you're with your mom you're never
safe you're always waiting you're always
this this this this you can't lean into
it your body's circling back four wins
normal when's normal when's normal
when's normal
my guess is i'd be willing to bet you
and i don't have a lot of money so it
would be a really lame yet
that your childhood wasn't as rosy as
you remember it
is that fair
i think my parents uh she traveled a lot
so
for her work
and they did a really and i know this
sounds corny
i'm going to think about that after we
get off the call hey don't explain
you're talking to me there is no corny
we're good same thing they did i lived
in the middle of about a thousand acres
that was divided up amongst all of our
extended family okay and so when mom
went dad stayed home
and we saw her every morning and every
night
there was when i listened to other calls
they said oh my mom went off and did
this or my
that i it wasn't there
i remember when it started because it
was so different from the behavior that
had been there previously okay um yeah
she was absent a lot because it was she
was gone working but you had family
connectivity that you were rooted to
right
yes yes
and you also have
woven through the genetic fabric and
behavioral fabric experiential fabric of
your family
mental illness that's generations old
right
yes yes and so
my guess is you had a
your dad is some kind of saint is that
fair
yes he sounds like an incredible man
um what you just described to me
externally i'm gonna be super unfair is
that okay we're we're friends just
picture you and me we're at a bar we're
hanging out i'm gonna be unfair but no
i'm doing it with a smile on my face
okay okay um
what you just described to me a thousand
acre place
with generations it sounds like a
compound
it sounds like a family compound that we
have hidden ourselves into the woods
which sounds very much like the bugs in
the fbi we're going to hide out here and
create a family is that am i onto
something
yeah okay even my friends always joked
when they came over that we were a
closed society there you go right it's
like an night shyamalan movie right so
you're you've got this you've got this
thing so here's what i want to tell you
the
instability you see in your mom
my guess is has threads all throughout
your childhood
and that doesn't negate the fact that
you love this woman and it breaks your
heart to see her like this and it is
stone terrifying to think this is where
i end up one of the gaps we have when
we're grieving what used to be and what
is
is that we
lionize what used to be so great or it
was so awful
and this is so great or this is so bad
and sometimes when you're working with
it helps to flatten it out and to really
dig into the truth of some of the
narratives it it doesn't make it any
better that your mom's struggling like
it is but it makes you feel less bonkers
and it lets your body not be so reactive
like oh
this is how this is manifesting this now
but we were on a trajectory here
and so
there's something about just accepting
mom
i i don't like that language that's your
mom
what i do like is
grieving
saying i had this picture when i was 13
i see my friends and their moms
i wanted my mom to be somebody that was
gonna be all excited about my wedding
and that we could go to the store and
then we could drink a little bit too
much with and we could she could tell me
dirty jokes and i'd be like mom don't
say that i had that picture of my mom
and it's not gonna happen
and let your body feel that
that's grief
that's ownership of it and it sucks
it hurts so bad
and when you can do that over a period
of time this isn't a one-shot thing this
is a way of being
a acknowledgement and internalization
then it's not about accepting just the
way mom is you know i accept that the
economy crashes i can't think about it i
don't know i didn't do anything he just
crashed
um i accept that
facebook tracks everybody so i don't use
facebook right so i accept things i
don't do that with my mom i want to love
my mom
but i can only truly plug into
to my mom when i am truly honest and
i've owned the stories
own the reality
and that's hard but it's necessary
some quick ways you can own that story
is to write your mom a series of letters
about what it was like to watch her
slowly get more and more scared
a way you can own that is to be with
your sisters or your brothers and you
all talk about it too
you are open with each other and you'll
talk about it
okay way you can own it is to be highly
intentional about what your life in the
future is going to look like
and start reverse engineering how do we
get there
because right now this is a story that's
holding you down
and that leads me to this
one of the demons of this
so you've heard the phrase um
like bipolar schizophrenia
um there is a strong genetic component
but
i love the way bernay brown says it
genetics loads the gun and environment
pulls the trigger
learned experience sets some of these
things off okay so the wiring might be
there for when x y and z happens so you
go back and you look at mom and say we
don't know what it is
it could have been a complex number of
things it could have been a long slow
slide it could have been
that
genetically speaking she had kindling
set up gasoline on there she just needed
a spark and there it went right
and what you're gonna do is start now
working with a counselor closely
getting a crew of people and begin
setting up different experiences that
are different than the ones that are
generational do you still live on the
compound
i do not okay
and do you have friends in community
that are outside of that gang
yes do you find yourself leaning into
conspiracy theories and looking over
your shoulders or are you free from that
only when i get manic do i get paranoid
but past there no i moved out of state i
bought a house out of state okay i left
the whole scenario
genetics some genetics are
this genetic is not a predetermination
this is not a period at the end of your
sentence
okay is it a possibility okay yep i'm
never gonna lie to you it is it is
does it have to happen is it inevitable
absolutely not
well what i'll tell you is
if you live a life without hope
and you live a life of isolation and
running
my guess is i have no data to back this
up okay so this is me spitballing okay
okay the inflammatory processes in your
body
the fear mechanisms in your body
will participate in the switching on of
genetic predispositions to protect you
from what's coming
and so if i'm you i'm going to partner
with a counselor probably maybe even a
psychiatrist at this point
prophylactically and say what do i need
to start doing now thoughts i need to
have behaviors i need to have actions i
need to take community members i need to
be around what can i start doing now
and it might be exercise and meditation
and
partridge in a periphery all this stuff
what can i start doing now
so that when i feel the
leanings this away i know okay here we
go and i've got this bedrock of
behaviors that i already leaned towards
i've got this bedrock of thoughts i've
got this community that i can lean on
when things get
here we go here we go here we go right
when it starts spinning and you know
when you're heading down a manic road
right yeah you can feel it generally i
start getting angry and i'm like why why
this is that why so you know you can go
up and then you get everyone thinks it's
fun but it can actually go at an angle
where you're hyper angry at other people
oh raged out and you also like you it
also is like here we go right because
you're gonna get more done than anybody
right so it's both uh
it's it's a uh it's the worst yeah
listen
you've got hope
and if you get anything out of this call
it's grieve your mom and
never let that light go out
keep walking towards
that light of hope
okay okay your story's not over all
right your story's not over your tour's
not over hang on the line i'm gonna give
you i'm gonna give you a copy too of own
your past change your future that's
exactly what i'm talking about here um
it's it's brand new book it's what's
gonna i want you to read it i want you
to work through it and then i want you
to give me a call back okay
thank you for loving your mom
thank you for doing the hard work coming
up of grieving this is who she was and
this is who she is and i love her for
who she is i gotta boundaries gotta be
safe and all that stuff and
my future's not over yet